we have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime you want to chat with me
that voicemail number is 2192 david p
here's a question about a sports related
political story that took place over the
weekend
hey david i was just wondering what your
thoughts are about the cleveland indians
being forced to change their name
um basically just because of a
minority falsely claiming racism i mean
this is a team
whose name has been established for over
a century
and i can't believe i'm saying this i
feel dirty saying this but i
really agree with what donald trump said
a while ago
this this really should not have
happened um i'd love to hear your
thoughts about it
so listen here here's the deal all right
um
it is a very bad argument to say that
because a team has had a certain name
for a long time
it's wrong to change it society changes
culture changes and there were lots of
things that we did
it's actually it's sort of the
fundamental
pillar of conservatism keep doing things
a certain way
because we've been doing them a certain
way terrible argument
it's a completely logically fallacious
argument here's my thought about the
cleveland indians changing their name to
the cleveland guardians
uh i don't really care i don't think
it's a big deal
these are decisions that are made in a
marketplace of ideas
the team has decided they're going to go
with cleveland guardians because
indians um is considered you know i
don't know that we have to use the term
racist but just
the the reference to indians in this way
combined with the logo
of the team hearkens back to
pejorative and xenophobic uses of the
term i guess i would say that that's
sort of undeniable
whether the history and tradition
overrides the need to change it it's not
my call to make
the people now will decide do they no
longer want to support the cleveland
guardians because they don't like the
name
does it reek of woke culture to them
such that they will protest by no longer
going to visit the cleveland guardians
there's one really funny thing about
this though
when donald trump started space force
and they announced near the end of his
presidency
you've got you know marines soldiers all
this different stuff
the space force um members are
going to be guardians everybody on the
right was cheering it
and doing a standing ovation this is so
patriotic
these are the guardians etc
and now many of the same people are
saying guardians is lame for a baseball
team
explain to me how if guardians is
suitable
for actual members of a branch of the
armed forces
who actually are potentially someday
going to be in positions of having to
defend us with weapons and all this
stuff
it's it's alpha enough for the for them
but not for a baseball team that at the
end of the day is you know
swinging bats and hitting balls it's not
it's it's beta in that it's just inc
these people are pathetic
these people are pathetic so i find
myself mostly not caring about it
whether it's a mistake from the
standpoint of business for the cleveland
guardians to do this
we will see in the future all right and
quite frankly i don't care that much one
way or the other about this there's just
such uh such bigger issues
um i want to tell you that on today's
bonus show we are going to talk about
the new coveted requirements in france
and spain i will soon be in one of those
countries
am i pleased or disgusted at what i will
have to do
i will tell you on the bonus show and
much much
more get instant access to today's bonus
show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com we will see you then